welcome back to new rock stars i'm eric
boss and for all the confusing crap i've
been able to decode about wandavision
it's the
forest mystery that i've missed because
of these little tree mysteries
why the classic tv sitcoms you know the
simple
obvious question the non-marvel insanos
are asking like we have good guesses
why wanda is in this pocket reality what
it really is and
who is doing this to her but we haven't
why is gamora
enough about the choice of sitcom
homages to frame wanda's fantastical
crisis
like when you go back to the comics
house of m doesn't really do brady bunch
tom king's vision isn't exactly dick van
dyke the witchcraft of the scarlet witch
vision classic run
isn't bewitched-esque so where is this
tv land nonsense coming from like we get
marvel's trying to be bold and
genre-bending but for the purposes of
wanda's mystery
why is it taking the form of all these
tv sitcoms well elizabeth olsen
confirmed that this sitcom formula is
actually crucial to the show's deeper
secrets
she said the reason it's a sitcom shows
itself later in the show when kevin
feige told me
it didn't feel so bizarre it felt like a
great way to start our story
kevin feige explained that this sitcom
format represented a kind of
escapism from the horrors of the world
oh we need a hat for this he said
i would get ready for the day and watch
some old sitcom because i couldn't take
the news anymore getting ready to go to
set over the last few years i kept
thinking of how influential these
programs were on our society and all
myself
and how certainly i was using it as an
escape from the reality
where things could be tied up in a nice
bow in 30 minutes yeah it must be nice
for you to not to read the news
either way based on these quotes we are
looking for an answer that reflects
wanda's escapism and one that won't seem
so
bizarre once it's revealed so the
simplest explanation is that the sitcoms
represent
wanda's memories with vision wanda has
constructed his pocket reality maybe
with the help of some third party
sorcery
and she might have chosen these classic
sitcom formats because
these were a source of comfort and
escapism when she was holed up with
vision during the period in which they
fell
in love this began when wanda was under
house arrest with vision during civil
war
cooking up pepper cash and body slamming
each other to the basement for two years
after civil war wanda and vision were on
the run
wanda of sokovia court's fugitive we
caught up with him in edinburgh at the
top of
infinity war and by this time wanda had
mysteriously dropped her sokovian accent
perhaps that accent faded as a result of
wanda envisioned binging
a ton of classic american sitcoms to
burn time while they're on the run
because it's not like they could go for
a daytime walk through the park tv
would be their escapist distraction in
these tv formats would be fresh in
wanda's mind
as an example of what a happy family
looks like and would help wanda
transition her accent from eastern
european
to bland american shows like the big van
dyke show bewitch the brady bunch these
all exist in the mcu because remember
cap kept that list of cultural
references to catch up on and pretty
much everything is
on it seems like all of pop culture is
mcu canon especially based off of all of
tony stark's references
inside there so in the events that led
to one division whatever they were
when wanda has the opportunity to warp
her reality so that vision can be alive
once more
westview might take the form of the
sitcoms that defined the period
she was happiest with her synthazoid
watching these kind of sitcoms now some
are saying these sitcoms could just be
shows that want to grow up with as a
girl in sekovia but something tells me
an eastern european country like sokovia
might not have the more modern american
sitcoms especially like the ones that
are shown up in later wanavision
episodes
shows like modern family or malcolm in
the middle would not be in syndication
in a country like sokovia it's just far
more meaningful of an explanation if
these are titles that wanda envision
netflix and chill to now there is a
darker take on this that the sitcoms
could be what are just plain on the tv
as wanda's in a coma some theories are
speculating that westview is a
hallucination in wanda's mind as she's
being kept in a sort of catatonic state
to keep her from tearing the universe
apart
and that just the next room over some
guard is watching tv land reruns this is
kind of like the tommy westfall snow
globe explanation where all of saint
elsewhere took place inside the mind of
a special needs child
or the way music works in inception you
know where songs are audible just much
slower in the lower dream layers
but before i continue thanks to our
friends at bang energy for sponsoring
this video
bang every can of bang energy has zero
calories zero carbs zero sugar zero
artificial colors
each 16 ounce can contains 300
milligrams of caffeine
super creo team coq10 and bcaas
i am sipping on black cherry vanilla
it's like i have now found the only soda
flavor i want for the rest of my life i
drink a bang when i need to pick me up
in the morning or when i just need to
plow through a long video and i want my
mind to be alert which i know you guys
need it to be
check out bang on instagram get 25 off
your order at bang energy.com when you
use the code newrockstars25
there you can buy a variety pack of bang
energy or a whole pack of just your
favorite flavor editor john loves
radical skedaddle and off-screen
producer zack drinks their sweet tea
flavor
whereas i am team black cherry vanilla
thanks again to bang energy for
sponsoring this video get 25
off your order at bang energy.com using
the code newrockstars25
i'm not crazy about this idea it makes
wanda way less
active and clearly one division is an
exploration of wanda maximoff's reality
warping powers
not something being done to her mind in
episode 3 revealed that west view is a
real town in the real world so why go to
the trouble of building a town if you're
just gonna project the reality inside
the person's mind
actually a similar explanation justifies
the sitcoms as something happening not
inside wanda's mind but
vision's mind visions os rebooting
as a synthesis vision's consciousness
comes from a variety of sources
something we broke down a big question
episode human tissue vibranium
the mind stone jarvis and asgardian
magic really he was built to be the
final form body of ultron
a process that was interrupted remember
when ultron became sentient we saw his
awakening from his point of view
his mind's eye flashed through
historical media
until he woke up and murdered jarvis in
a hologram battle
now infinity war vision went offline and
now
one vision could be showing us the
process by which that corpse is rebooted
with wanda using her mind stone derived
powers to
enter vision's consciousness and try to
restore his soul
and like his predecessor ultron vision
could be relearning the story of
humanity via
historical media but in this case 20th
century american sitcoms i don't
mind this explanation ultron was just
mentioned in episode 3
but it would make one division more
about vision than
wanda and it wouldn't really explain why
westview exists in the real world i
think this series is clearly setting up
wanda's arc especially since she is
confirmed to come back in multiverse of
madness so a theory i posed in another
recent video
is that if we assume westview was warped
into a sitcom reality by a hex spell
cast by wanda
then these sitcoms could come from a
cursed object
like agnes cursed tv set just stay with
me on this
beyond the tv sitcom format playing an
important role on this show
the physical object of a television is
also important
it appears all over promo art the first
episode ends with vision
using a tv remote to switch us out of
the episode as a sword agent watches
this all go down
on a tv screen clearly the technology of
broadcast media is part of this
now the movie pleasantville is at least
an aesthetic inspiration
with objects switching a technicolor
within a monochromatic world i'm not
saying wanda got sucked into a tv show
like spider-man did but
she may have cast a hex alongside fellow
witch agnes that involved a tv set that
caused this spell to misfire
and trap wanda and agnes in a hellish
dimension displayed via the medium of
television but that theory is a bit
complicated i don't know if elizabeth
also would be like oh that's not too
bizarre so to simplify that theory we
might just need to involve an
unseen third party in which case these
sitcoms could be
wanda being tortured by a demon i know i
know but paul vetney keeps continuing to
tease this top secret surprise actor
coming
into the final episodes who will make us
look at the mcu in a whole new light an
actor that he previously said he had
wanted to work with for a long time
and that in one division a character
vision has fireworks with now we have
speculated that actor could be richard e
grant confirmed for the loki series
or evan peters rumored to be in the show
or one of the other x-men cast crossing
over the mcu
and although elizabeth olsen teased that
wandovision doesn't give too much
certainty as to whether there even is a
villain i think most of us still believe
this could be some dark demonic entity
whom agnes
is serving her quote-unquote husband
ralph
someone distracting wanda with the
classic tv escapism while he drains her
of her power
methesto or the grim reaper nightmare or
if we're looking for marvel villains who
love to use tv to torture people
mojo mojo does look a hell of a lot like
the devil with the yellow eyes from
legion a show that i believe directly
inspired wandavision
yeah i guess one of vision could be set
in the mojo verse
does that sound like that simple
explanation elizabeth olsen talked about
not really but uh
mojo's coming sooner or later so why not
sooner
which of these explanations sounds the
best to you comment down below this
hi i'm eric voss shirt is actually
available for purchase at our merch
store newrockstarsmerch.com along with a
ton of other great
nerdy designs including our limited
edition
unusual couples shirt all of these
support this channel directly
newrockstarsmerch.com
follow me on instagram at eavos follow
new rockstars and subscribe to rockstars
on youtube for breakdowns of everything
you love thank you for watching mojo i
know you always are
you